wenn du zu betrunken bist zu
ausgeschaltet um zu sagen nein halt
stopp ich will das nicht ich will keinen
Sex wenn du weinst wimmerst aber kein
klares Nein mehr über die Lippen bringst
wenn du jemanden wegstößt ich wegdrehst
aber nicht klar NEIN sagst ist die Sache
rechtlich völlig eindeutig werde ich
dann trotzdem anfasst küsst Sex mit dir
hat macht sich strafbar denn seit 2016
ist in Deutschland jede sexuelle
Handlung strafbar die gegen den
erkennbaren Willen einer anderen Person
vorgenommen wird fast ganz konkret jede
Form der Ablehnung ist ein nein nein
heißt nein egal wie das ausgedrückt wird
in einigen Ländern geht man noch einen
Schritt weiter in Spanien und Schäden
z.B gilt der Grundsatz ja heißt ja heißt
konkret sex ist nur erlaubt und legal
wenn ausdrücklich zugestimmt wurde die
große Schwierigkeit ist aber immer die
Beweisbarkeit denn Sex ist meistens was
zwischen zwei Menschen und Zeugen gibt
es selten